[Music]
hey guys we're back congratulations
episode four and this is the first ever
fourth episode of congratulations
and here we are we're holding strong our
numbers are holding strong and I'm
sitting down to record this I got my
coffee
mmm drinking it I love coffee man I know
uh if you really know about me you know
I love [ __ ] coffee and I don't know
what it is about the [ __ ] coffee that
I love so much because it's not like
it's the taste first of all this is my
drink I got an iced americano that's
what I do I get that every time I don't
[ __ ] around with those [ __ ] drinks
you know no no you know I don't get
those vanilla latte shit's with the the
45 grams of sugar or anything like that
I just basically actually I think is got
more important more than 45 grams I
think it's got I don't know I saw this
documentary called sugar man or
something this guy in Australia is
trying to you know take well not really
take down the sugar industry but he did
the supersize me thing where he tried to
take a bunch of sugar for like two
months and he gained like a lot of
weight and almost got cancer or some
[ __ ] in his liver shut down it's [ __ ]
up what's going on though with that [ __ ]
but anyway I so yeah but but try to yeah
just you got to eat like plants and [ __ ]
I mean you can eat like some sort of
meat but you got to eat [ __ ] mainly
plants and as many plants as you can
like you're just some [ __ ] you know
duck or some [ __ ] and not ducks I knew
it wasn't duck but duck sounds really
funny so I said duck but yeah so I'm
trying to like you know
i-i drinkin americano which has got no
sugar and it's just a black coffee it's
black espresso it's from the bean or
whatever and it's black it's black and
it's and it's bitter is [ __ ] but I got
used to it and so this is what I drink
for my caffeine and I love it because I
don't know if I like it or not you know
I mean I think the best things in life
are [ __ ] you can't figure out right and
I think people I think people agree with
that secretly even I mean that's what
becomes the biggest [ __ ] like look at
Kanye West or Lady Gaga they're the
biggest [ __ ] in the world this
because we can't figure him out we don't
even know if we don't even know if we
really know a [ __ ] Lady Gaga she
could be like an alien and Kanye West -
um but I think that I think that a
coffee is like not it's not that good I
love the smell of it I like the
experience of going and getting it I
love how there's always like one or two
crazy [ __ ] at a coffee shop
I've never been in a coffee shop where
there hasn't been one or two crazy
[ __ ] like I'm talking about
like 65 year old men that somehow made
it to 65 but just having a psychotic
break uh and just losing their mind also
why are people the [ __ ] the craziest
people are always just the craziest like
they never get a little bit crazy it's
so they're always talking about religion
and government I'm already getting so
far off track here I'm just talking
about how much I like coffee uh and I
like it because I don't know if I like
it I've been trying to figure it out for
15 years I've been going to these coffee
shops and drinking it in its bitter and
I drink and I drink like 3/4 of it and I
don't know if I like it I like having it
I like being at the coffee shop I like
to chill in part of it I like to looking
at my phone and doing emails while I'm
drinking it and then even if I show up
to like a radio station for like an
interview I love drinking the coffee - I
like getting a hot coffee sometimes cuz
they don't always have the iced
americano because you're in you know
some some [ __ ] building that you're
on like the fourth floor of a [ __ ]
fluorescent lighted building and you're
doing some radio station in Des Moines
but I love it because of that I love it
because I don't know if I love it does
that make sense
I don't know um I don't know if that
sentence that makes sense or not but
anyway I'm here I didn't do the road
this week I was I was here in LA I did
some shows in Los Angeles that were very
fun I did the Comedy Store and I'm just
trying to do you know I shoot my special
this weekend I shoot it on Friday I got
two shows in Vancouver they're sold out
and so I'm really excited to do that and
get this out I've been working on this
material for like a year and a half
maybe it's some of it even longer and
some of it less but I got like 65
minutes I'm just trying to I'm trying to
top-load it - I'm trying to put the good
[ __ ] in the beginning because I put the
good [ __ ] at the end last time and I
think that people [ __ ]
I have attention spans it's the size of
a [ __ ] beetle and so I'm doing it I'm
doing that and I've been really [ __ ]
excited to get that out of the way and
just finish it out and have it come out
this summer so by the way did you see
what happened I don't know if you've
listened to the last episode of
congratulations but I said if if I said
not me because I'm not famous enough but
I said if somebody slammed if somebody
said something shitty about Beyonce it
would be news and how ridiculous that
was and then literally the next day
Carlos Santana who is like the best
guitar player in the world or some ship
said that Beyonce isn't a singer and
that Adele is a singer and Beyonce is
more of a show you know person and it
was news it was like all over the
[ __ ] Twitter and [ __ ] that's that and
everyone was like oh Carlos Santana is a
[ __ ] for saying it it happened I
don't mean a [ __ ] prefer to be a
prophet with this [ __ ] Grammy [ __ ]
but it happened
geeky are teenagers by the way in all
honesty how geeky are teenagers
that's a [ __ ] that's like the the the
cruelest joke that [ __ ] if you
believe in God that's the cruelest joke
that God played that you're like a you
know a twelve-year-old and you're you're
you're you're getting some confidence
because you're finally figuring out you
know you figured out how to walk if you
get out how to talk you figure out how
to assimilate with friends and then you
know maybe they start getting crushes on
some girls or girl if you're a girl you
get a crush on a guy and then all of a
sudden you grow a foot and a half
you get pimples all over your [ __ ]
face and you look awful you look awful
dude you ever seen a [ __ ] teenager I
know you have but have you ever looked
at someone who's like fifteen like
really looked at somebody with like
shorts on knobby as [ __ ] knees you know
nothing fits for some reason if you're
the same height as a teenager it fits if
you're an adult but if you're a teenager
this [ __ ] doesn't fit you get shorts and
they're like so far above your knees or
so below your knees you look like you
[ __ ] put the shorts on before you
shrunk or or or grew and then you
[ __ ] you got like a polo shirt on if
you're a guy or even if you're a girl
even better
you got like a green polo shirt on and
cargo pants and you got like a high
ponytail with like [ __ ] if you're a
girl you and but you still got like hair
coming down over your ears and your nose
is all big and [ __ ] and you laugh like
ah ha ha ha
and you look [ __ ] gross dude and your
teeth are gross and your gums are all
big for some reason the [ __ ] is wrong
with teenagers god I'm so glad I'm out
of that [ __ ] I think about it sometimes
I'm 36 and I think about I think I think
out I'm not a teenager boners all the
time if you're a dude for no reason
you're just sitting in the back of a car
and all of a sudden [ __ ] a boner
comes up
like it's a groundhog trying to see it
shadow god dude you're in the back of a
[ __ ] bus and all of a sudden you just
got some squirty boner so gross dude so
[ __ ] gross I don't know how it works
for girls as a teenager but but you're
just some [ __ ] and you haven't even
have had sex yet but you're like mmm and
you got this big-ass boner and you're
trying to you're trying to [ __ ]
you're like put a thumb wheel should I
put it thumb wheel ill gross gross so
[ __ ] gross in your pimply faced with
boners and [ __ ] with cargo shorts on and
a [ __ ] green polo shirt you're the
grossest kind of [ __ ] person
congratulations you're 15 we were all
that way though unless we died before
then which would be [ __ ] so sad oh
you know I'm not going to edit that part
out even though it's a downer I see
these [ __ ] teenagers sometimes just
like clomping around with their big-ass
shoes trying to figure out their style
you know like who are they with like
maybe they have a necklace out outside
of their [ __ ] shirts like their uh
Scott wolf in a party of five like
frosted tips or some [ __ ] yeah and
you're trying to figure out life right
you're trying to figure out life like
you go to parties you got nothing going
on you just go to party you got nothing
going on you're doing it you're in high
school you got nothing going on you got
to do your homework by the way I still
[ __ ] swear to god I'm 36 and I still
am so happy that I don't that I don't
think about that I think oh I'm so glad
I don't have homework for tomorrow I
legitimately still feel that way I am so
happy I'm not a [ __ ] teenager and I'm
so happy that I don't have to go to
parties and like [ __ ] remember that
feeling that you'd have
remember that feeling you'd have showing
up at somebody's house from like another
school like ìyeah st. Francis is having
a party and you're like ah I don't know
about those st. Francis people but I
guess I'll go I'll try to go and you go
and you show up and your buddies forward
explore and you got your [ __ ] cargo
shorts on and you get out and then the
people to look who the people from you
looks cooler here and then that oh god I
don't know what they plead we playing
now me goes back when I was playing they
played it when I would go to school they
played the whitish [ __ ] ever they played
Dave Matthews Oh
or what was that one song I always think
about when I think about the past
David group not David gray Babylon was
that [ __ ] living on hell living
around
hey Babineaux whatever the [ __ ] that
song was remember that song that was the
most high school song of all time you
could listen to that song you could be
60 and you could hear that song and
you'd be like oh I got to get to math
class that's the most high school is
[ __ ] song I've ever heard of my life and
then you go to the party and it and it's
like yeah I I didn't drink but like
people were drunk as [ __ ] and they were
15 and a half and then and then it got
late night here here was the least
favorite part of the party for me you're
[ __ ] 15 or 16 year at a party and some
[ __ ] [ __ ]
the music's off and now there's like you
know 25 people there and some [ __ ]
finds a guitar and then plays a guitar
for everybody hey dude you deserve to
not eat for three days
if you do that if everyone's having a
good time and [ __ ] laughing and
talking and having conversations and
then some [ __ ] finds the goddamn
guitar and starts playing you know what
he starts playing - he doesn't start
playing Babylon or Jay Dave Matthews or
[ __ ] that's a book you know what he
[ __ ] starts playing he starts playing
some [ __ ] he finds the chords where
he starts playing and he starts rapping
over it is what he does he's
are singing a Snoop Dogg song he starts
singing that [ __ ] 1 2 3 into the far
and and he's [ __ ] playing the [ __ ]
chords and he's got the green polo shirt
on with the cargo pants and flip-flops
dude I will murder you dude
you deserve to not eat for three days
that's what you deserve that's what you
[ __ ] deserve if you you lunatic
narcissist everyone's having a good time
but hey dude let me [ __ ] play the
same four chords over and over again and
[ __ ] sing a jayo felony song dude
I'll murder you you deserve to not eat
for three days
you deserve to look at people eating for
three days but not get to eat that same
food that they're eating dude we got to
stop this man if you're play guitar at a
party and you're not you know Dave
Matthews quit it if you're playing a
guitar at a party and you're not the guy
from matchbox 20 by you playing the
guitar at a party and you aren't the
[ __ ] I can't even think of a guy I
came to think of another guitar player
that's like would be funny what a load
of [ __ ] loser I am I don't know [ __ ]
all I wouldn't know is the chainsmokers
like I'm trying to be current but I'm
like I want to say like the [ __ ] I
don't know you just don't do that have
some [ __ ] humility with your
puka-shell necklace on I'll rip it off I
want to go back to 15 and a half so I
can kick all those [ __ ] asses I
want to study hard I want to go I want
to go to Asia and like learn the fine
mr. martial arts like I'm not even
talking about like grappling I'm not
even talking about that [ __ ] I want to
go to Asia and I want to [ __ ] wear
all brown
like a burlap sack that's all I want to
wear and have a [ __ ] teacher that's
like a hundred and seventy-five that's
so powerful with his mind and I want to
learn all the finest ain't out like I
want him to start me out I want him to
start me out like kicking a leaf or
blowing a [ __ ] blowing some sugar
across the table and I'll be like what
does this have to do with anything
anybody like this is how you learn
inside there you mind like I don't get
it and for [ __ ] three years I want to
blow some sugar or salt across the table
and then I want it and then I want to
[ __ ] wear a only burlap brown burlap
[ __ ] that looks like Kanye West would
have designed it if he was alive in the
year 1200 and I want to study that [ __ ]
and then in [ __ ] three years later I
want him to finally throw I want that
178 year because now that's how old he
is because you add three because it
three is it I want that 178 year old guy
to finally show me what it's like to
[ __ ] you know block not even punch
just block block a [ __ ] and he's just
gonna like block a nerf gun but whatever
the equivalent of that is in because I
cam not even ready to do punches and
then [ __ ] five years later I want to
throw my first punch and he's almost
dead and he's 180 [ __ ] whatever and
then just study define and eat I want
him to show me what to eat - and breathe
and just [ __ ] learn that [ __ ] and
then thirty years when I'm you know 70 I
want to transport back to being 15 and a
half years old and I want to go back to
Glendale California or whoever the [ __ ]
that's pretty Armenian but like the
widest place ever like somewhere in the
middle of the country and I want to
enroll in school and I want to go get
invited to a party and I want I want
somebody to be playing the [ __ ]
guitar I want it to get really late at
night tour wherever the [ __ ] new
music is stops
people are just assimilating and just
kind of hanging out talking about if you
having a real good time like it's the
end of the night where everybody is like
man this party really we did it this was
a great [ __ ] party and then I won't
want some white [ __ ] to pick up
the guitar and start playing the [ __ ]
hip-hop song hits of today and singing
them and right when he gets that first
[ __ ] whatever the version is you know
of the Snoop Dogg song is 1 2 3 into the
4 I want to [ __ ] drag him out I just
want to light them up with fists of fury
where people are like holy [ __ ] how the
[ __ ] did that guy my name would be Paul
or you know because I have to go
undercover
look how Paul lit that [ __ ] up
and as I'm kicking the [ __ ] out of that
dude break just bash I don't even I bash
in the guitar I want to break the guitar
and then bash the [ __ ] out of him and
just almost choke him with his puka
shell necklaces and just slapping him on
the head with his [ __ ] flip-flops I
want to understand in that moment why
that [ __ ] 175 year old man had me
blow that salt or that sugar across that
because the breath was important in
kicking a [ __ ] ass you know
that's what I wanted that's how much I
don't like that and then I want to be
like you desert you're not going to eat
for three days
does it even make sense what I'm saying
I don't know yeah I mean you know this
is just what I feel and also like but
it's just just what I feel man and also
and also I love coffee I feel like I got
to balance it out because I get into
these tangents and these [ __ ] things
where like I'm start talking and then I
start talking about what I'm really
passionate about and what I'm really
passionate about is what the [ __ ] is you
know I guess upsets me but I don't want
to be that guy I don't want to be a
[ __ ] 80 year old guy who's like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] that so I actually been trying
to think about things that make me happy
to write like teenagers are geeky and
[ __ ] and I don't like when people play
guitar but I love coffee right I love
coffee so that balances it out that's
what I try to do I love stand-up I do
the stand-up and I love doing it right I
don't know though
Harr at a party though man you know the
balls the [ __ ] balls to have gel in
your hair and play guitar at a party the
[ __ ] balls I was online man and I
speaking of singing at a party and being
a teenager dude there's there's there's
legitimately seven
there's legitimately well therefore I
guess are 14 or 13 or maybe 12 or I
think some of these [ __ ] are 11
dude and they're like they make albums
like but it's different than like the
Jackson 5 used to do it it's not like
Michael Jackson just like dancing around
in his in his like shiny I guess it
would be like almost like a looked like
he belongs in the WWF but like they'll
have these like rosy-cheeked 11 year
olds singing that they they start on I
think I start on social media I think I
start on like Twitter and Instagram and
and and they'll post songs of them
singing but they'll be like but but
they're like heartthrobs to like I don't
know who they are threads to other
11-year olds or like usually it's like
the you get the younger crowd usually
unless you're like an adult but like if
you're 18 and you're a [ __ ] smash hit
whether you're a singer or a model or an
actor you make like 12 year olds like
swoon right like that's the [ __ ]
thing like these guys aren't that are on
like Scheldt like the Vampire Diaries
like they're all like 30-something but
they I think the people who watched her
in their 20s these 11 year old and 12
year old like pop stars and their
sensations dude I was on one of these
guys instagrams and he was like thanks
Germany and yet it was holding up his
guitar who's by the way bigger than he
is
the guitar is bigger than this guy
because he hasn't gone through puberty
dude this guy's an embryo holding a
guitar like thanks Germany the crowds
are four times the size as mine sad I'm
36 and I'm like a [ __ ] homeless guy
compared to this 11 year old killing it
they're like the new Justin Bieber's man
there's a bunch of them dude there's a
bunch of them and they're like
heartthrobs with braces on who are they
who are they who what are the a girl
dude I'm imagine a [ __ ] six-year-old
Oh imagine is six year old thinking all
an eleven year old is a heartthrob oh
just being like I gotta get that album I
gotta get that album like a six year old
like ma will you can I get the album to
a [ __ ] 11 year old singing oh man
dude that's so funny that's so [ __ ]
funny these guys have like five million
Instagram followers and they're more how
they're making money dude well their
moms and dads are making money and then
they're probably like and then they post
[ __ ] like inspirational [ __ ] like love
you cuties yeah you're 11 ma you're a
cutie you can't say someone's acuity if
you're 11
you're the QT what the [ __ ] bro that's
so funny that's so funny dude god that's
funny
is crazy dude look up some of these guys
I don't know yeah here we go
I'm on this website I'm on Billboard
2121 music's hottest young stars look at
the bigger picture of them Wow the
picture of them the picture that the
users like five of them or six of us
five of them and they all look like the
picture of the person you post when it
like after they die you know what I mean
like when they're like oh like like on
those Forensic Files shows when they're
like when they're like they show the
picture of the person that the episode
is about this is the picture they use
for the [ __ ] I don't know why they
didn't use more professional pictures
but they got these 2121 this must be old
cuz Bieber's in it I think he's 22 now I
don't know but look at these other
rappers on here - I don't think I guess
damn I didn't really as Martin garrix
was so young this guy looks like a
[ __ ] whoa this guy looks like he just
eats candy all day long fifth harmony
these some of these big names are like
jokes
fifth harmony when there's five of them
Oh cute there's a guy named Austin
Mahone or Mahoney Wow I mean why are
their names all like that - Austin
Mahoney Troye Sivan and Troy spelled TR
oh ye oh my god
Cody Simpson there's another one he
that's a big one right I think he's real
big I think he was really [ __ ] up hats
and I saw him at UH I saw a picture of
him on at Coachella one time and I was
like oh alright
I'm a different person um Scotty
McCreery 2121 this guy looks like he's
like this guy look I'm out of it I don't
know any these guys it says he's 20 this
guy legitimately looks like he's 35 and
he's tricking everybody who looks like
the [ __ ] guys like that like deta
was it was a dare was friends like I bet
you know I bet I could [ __ ] pass for
a popstar I'm gonna learn how to sing
and I'm gonna [ __ ] learn how to sing
and I'm gonna be a [ __ ] I'll he was
on season 10 of American Idol I'm
surprised that [ __ ] still makes people
huh here's one here's 100 these people
act dong musician that's what they're
called 2121 I think they're Asian they
look Asian oh boy the way this guy's
dressed oh my god Wow
you ever feel like some people the way
they dress it's not like they're like
like they're not trying to like be
handsome it's like they know how they
look and so they're like well this is
what I got is the best I got so I'm
gonna just kind of try and disguise my
ugliness you ever feel like that I you
know that that's how they do like people
who that would really like look wise
they were they were dressed or they were
they like they were you know given the
raw end of the deal so like they get
tweed pants and [ __ ] big big circular
sunglasses and shave side of their head
and they're like all right this is what
I got to do I'll just be different I
mean nobody like Brad Pitt ever really
did that you know they're just like I'll
just use my regular hair and wear what
what they give me
that's so funny dude yeah I guess that's
what you got to do though I would do it
too I'm not saying I'm [ __ ]
good-looking I'm just a regular guy
though like I'm just like I'm not into
all that [ __ ] I don't think like I go a
little bit with the fashion like I'm
into the [ __ ] longer shirts but
you're not going to hand me one of those
[ __ ] glasses that that flip up you
know or the with the sunglass it with
the sunglasses that you can flip down
and flip
um yeah incredible achtung musician or
something I don't know heartthrob man
they come in all ages I want to be the I
want to be the [ __ ] I want to be I
don't want to be a heartthrob until I'm
[ __ ] 75 and I want I want like 62
year olds to be screaming at my when I
get out of a [ __ ] black car you know
that would be awesome I don't even know
what I would be famous for I guess I
mean I would try I would still do
stand-up but I want to be famous Amos
chef that makes like a dish that's just
out of this world that 62 year old women
who are married just can't get enough of
and they're like are Chris D'Elia did
you see Chris D'Elia and I cut out of
the black car like all right no pictures
for me or maybe I'm like good with it
I'm like sure I'll sign it I'll sign it
just [ __ ] myself so old like 82 sure
I'll sign it and they don't even care
yeah I signed my my calendar and he
pissed his pants sorry honey
her mama's dead hope you like my dishes
I think it is really going off the rails
here this is what happens for Episode
four on how many guests what the [ __ ] do
you want
I hope you're in your cubicle [ __ ]
enjoying this but yeah so I got dates
coming up Milwaukee
Madison it's still cold as [ __ ] there I
think so I'm gonna be hitting that I
don't know is that technically the
Midwest I think it is and I got West
Palm Beach
I go to West Palm Beach I go to Tempe
I'm going to Tempe in May which is
hotter than [ __ ] not Mars that's a
cold one
think pretend Mars is hot so the analogy
works but yeah so I'm going to attempt
II I'm going to a West Palm Beach and
West Palm Beach is that town dude is
like this it's like The Truman Show it's
like where they shot The Truman Show
everybody's so nice and it's like
perfect looking and it's like everything
is a set you go to Starbucks and it
looks like they're shooting there so I
got to go there I don't know so I'm
going lots of different [ __ ] places
so look at my website Chris D'Elia calm
and check it out I feel like this
[ __ ] I literally feel like podcasts
are cool man I feel like I'm at it I've
been looking about disc jockey like I'm
just like I check out the website on
Chris Leo Cobb you got all a lot of
interesting dates coming up go to
Virginia Beach go into bit walky go into
West Palm Beach tell me a little bit
about West Palm Beach tell me about how
you feel about West Palm Beach Chris
well ya know I feel like it's the truman
show ha ha
is that right it's just amazing we're
gonna we're gonna stop this for a break
we're gonna get it to some songs welcome
back to you we will come back to you it
will be listening to ask you a little
bit more about the Bieber roast is what
we're gonna talk about even though it's
gonna be boring as [ __ ] and even though
everyone has asked you about that
already we're gonna ask you about to be
Bruce who can see hey Phil about
targeted Ludacris and we heard there was
a little bit of a scuffle so we're right
back after this we're gonna play some
David Gray leave me alone leave me alone
leave me alone
hey what's up we're bagging Chris so
good so tell us a little bit about the
Bieber roast she talked about be morose
tell us tell us how was ludicrous Lucas
maybe there was a little bit of a
scuffle at the end of the thing baby you
guys had a little bit of a darker a
little bit uh he was asleep there's a
little bit upset with her jokes
Solis about uh Zoe Sarah yeah I don't
know I mean you know I I basically he
thought I said something that I didn't
say and he was upset and not a guy who
said was it that interesting
yeah it's people in life sometimes often
say something it attributed to Scylla
don't know it it would've come back in a
little bit we're gonna go ahead and play
a little bit of a song here
hey we come back what can ask you about
her and what would happen I show Whitney
that's whatever that show Whitney we're
gonna everybody stay tuned for some Dave
Matthews will write back you play on
Play on Play on Play on Play on Play on
Play on Play on Play on pan-pan pan-pan
[Music]
blimpy plan plan plan
everybody Rebecca Chris Chris whatever
their show Whitney well you know it just
got cancelled because not not a not a
lot of people kept watching it so it's
just pretty much what happens you know
as a show gets canceled and um and
that's that's pretty much it
all right that's that's pretty much it
obvious I don't know why I asked that
goddamn question but sometimes you know
sometimes we up here we don't know what
to say
so we'll just ask you a question that uh
well I'll ask you questions that even
though everybody knows the goddamn
answer to it's palpable it's palpable
for our audience so when I say something
like what happened that show Whitney
even though I know God there well what
happens to joseline to dizzle is that is
that people don't watch them and then
shows get canceled because that's
literally the only way unless Leslie
character dies but they didn't died out
did they did really die no [ __ ] no did
you die though she did been one of the
neighbors that should die no they did
the show's got cancelled because well
because obviously nobody was watching it
so anyway we're going to get go to a
song
uh and we'll come back your wife she a
pop soda where we had some fun questions
we're gonna play a little game with you
it's gonna be really fun
for all of our listeners I'll be back
after we're gonna be played again okay
okay we're getting a little a little
Stevie Wonder uh that's how all
interviews go by the way and you're just
trying to [ __ ] we're gonna take a
request how about how about how about
that there's people I'm not doing it I'm
not this is me back to me being me and
not being the interview of me right now
to you guys how about I I think
legitimately if the moment you decide
for the first time whether you're in
traffic or you're at your office or
you're at home or whatever the [ __ ]
you're dealing with your kids the moment
the moment you decide I'm gonna I'm
gonna call into a radio station and
request a song that's the beginning of
the of your of the end I think that you
are have started to suffer a psychotic
break - nowadays - in the year 2007 to
be like you know what I really want to
listen to some neo right now and call up
hot 107 or whatever the [ __ ] radio
station you are hi this is hot Auto
seven I'm Rick Rick Orson Johnny and the
Bosch call in with your request we got
we got Steven on line one is that right
Steven what do you listen to
hey man I really want to listen to some
neo if you got anything neo really I
know he's really popular in Europe but
huge neo fan Li I got you coming up stay
tuned and listen to it stay tuned and
listen up we might play it in the next
45 minutes and then is sit there by the
way Siri [ __ ] I don't know why
Syria's literally I was doing that and
it showed up they literally was like
went to a link for I in iTunes to watch
the fan with Robert DeNiro and Wesley
Snipes I swore to God I have no idea um
but yeah - oh because I said I'm a big
neo fan I don't know I don't know Steven
neo fan may sound like Siri fan but yeah
like what you you literally so you
listen to the radio first of all you're
listening to the radio which is which is
fine but that's a dying thing anyway
right like most people are listening
when I don't know about most people but
a lot people listen to podcast and [ __ ]
or catching up on the walking dead from
their Netflix or their there on demand
or recorded it but now so you're
listening the radio which is already a
dying form I think and then you think I
got it you know what I really want to
hear some neo and so you call up [ __ ]
Johnny in the bash you wait you wait 20
minutes for [ __ ] a guy to be like hey
we're going to get a [ __ ] we would want
to hear neo and say okay cool we're
going to patch in and they gotta wait
again for another blab three minutes and
then the guy comes on hey what hey
what's up now it's Steven from [ __ ]
Arlington and then you say yeah I want
to a man first of all love the way you
do it I'm gonna listen to some neo and I
haven't got it for you cut up and then
you sit there and you wait for neo and
you're at your cubicle or you're doing
with the kids or you're in traffic and
you're just waiting for your song to
come on imagine being in traffic waiting
for your neo song to come on just a
ma'am imagine waiting in your traffic
imagine sitting in traffic waiting for a
neo song that's the beginning of your
psychotic break that's your psychotic
break that's your small little you know
precursor to the huge earthquake in your
mind which is by the way sounds for sure
like a David Gray song small an
earthquake small little
precursor to the earthquake in your mind
linear head is it David gray I don't
even know I got to look it up david gray
i think it is whatever happened to him I
like that song battle on gray David gret
I wrote David gray Babylon here we go
yep owner he's probably still killing it
you fight he's making so much money even
still
he's probably those guys has those fan
bases since I hope he's got a best of
album done retire if you have a best of
album retire you did it go buy a [ __ ]
leopard yep how old is he how old is is
48 years old by a leopard retire you're
done you got about thirty years left if
you're lucky Damien Rice another guy
retire um dude yeah but by the way if
you want to listen to neo instead of
calling up the radio station and waiting
an hour for the neo song to play pick up
that phone you are going to use to call
the radio station and YouTube a [ __ ]
neo song you two-bit YouTube Anil song
congratulations you can do that YouTube
a neo song you can YouTube a neo song
even if you don't have Apple music you
call it a radio station you got a phone
use the phone to YouTube a neo song so
weird man who YouTube songs people
YouTube songs I'm gonna be a guy at
YouTube songs I also wanna be a guy who
you leaves YouTube comments imagine
leaving a youtube comment and being like
hey man don't dude what's with the
[ __ ] part where he comes out of the
car and then
and then imagine coming to be the guy
who comments to that comment bro he
mentions it in the last vid in the last
song so he just did it this one just so
you know guy from Australia and I'm in
Winnipeg oh thanks guy
thumbs up dude what the [ __ ] man calling
in to a radio stick calling in to a
radio station to hear a [ __ ] Damien
Rice song uh by uh oh is [ __ ] I don't
understand it it's so [ __ ] your time
management dude do another thing instead
of that ah man I love it though I love
it I love that [ __ ] I love people that
do that even though I've [ __ ] even
though the guy at the guitar at the
party I don't like that guy is sincerely
deserves to not eat for three days but
if you [ __ ] call in to hear a neo
song on a [ __ ] drive home oh you're
wonderful bro and I don't use that word
wonderful you're wonderful man stand in
a field and run your hand through the
[ __ ] weeds you're wonderful I hope
you get a nice pretty girl with a dress
on you know that's wonderful man um yeah
so I don't know man I covered a lot of
[ __ ] today it's been 42 minutes you know
I don't want to keep these podcasts long
I look at other podcast man they're like
an hour and a half Joe Rogan does 3
hours plus I'm just not that smart I run
out of steam and my back starts to
[ __ ] hurt I'm trying to eat healthy
though after I saw that documentary I'm
trying to [ __ ] work out keep fit and
be healthy and I I'm I ate tuna today
and I'm gonna try and eat up as many
[ __ ] vegetables as I can how many so
many vegetables I'm gonna [ __ ] out a
whole carrot in the toilet not going to
I can't even I can't even flush it
because it's legitimately a carrot I
just get
I just got to grab that out of there and
even the green part on the tops gonna be
on it even though I didn't eat that part
I'm gonna eat so many vegetables today
it's gonna be ridiculous and I mean you
think I'm gonna juice them no because
that's not how nature intended us to eat
them dude they made a [ __ ] celery
stick so I'm gonna eat that [ __ ]
celery stick how dare I try to juice it
and only get the good [ __ ] out the tasty
[ __ ] nah bro
gimme a nah I'll pull it out of the
ground and eat that and eat the dirt
give me some rope there's rocks in there
too I'll eat them um so yeah so I'm know
I'm trying to not do this sugar thing
bro you'll get cancer yo you listening
to this don't eat it
put it down you [ __ ] some of you
people are about to put that [ __ ] in
your mouth right now some fries or
whatever the [ __ ] with the chipotle
sauce put it down so yeah I don't know
man but check my website for dates got
them all coming up let me look up what I
got coming up here actually and send me
some some questions oh you know what I
could actually there were some good
questions this week I could actually
talk about them there were some good
ones I thought um yesterday this is
Johnny hatch back on Twitter yesterday I
saw an adult woman call her adult
boyfriend Pookie bear on Facebook can
you discuss pet names here's the thing
about pets and pet names whoops there
goes the phone listen okay here's the
thing about pet names they're fine if
you're in the relationship right if you
call someone a Pookie bear that's it's
cute if to hear you're good to me it's
like a girl like if you have a
girlfriend and she's wearing a [ __ ]
fedora it's cute because she's her
girlfriend in the fedora but if you see
a girl wearing a fedora boner removal if
you see a random girl and she's hot
wearing a fedora boner removal just so
you know does it have a feather in the
Hat
extreme boner inversion right but if
your girl has a fedora on with a feather
in the Hat it's it's cute and you're
going to talk like a 1920s gangster
you're gonna be that guy come up ahead
damn I love those gams boner-inducing
not your girl
boner removal right so if you're calling
someone a Pookie bear and you're out in
public and I got to hear that [ __ ] time
to set up the firing squad but ya know I
just you know I think it's cute to do it
I think it's cute to do it but to have
to hear it in a in a in a Chipotle or
having to hear it in like a Cheesecake
Factory now dude that's just out it I go
to lunch dude my hands are tied now
um what's here's another one Q dizzle
twelve what's the weirdest gift a fan
has ever given you tried to give you I
had a guy come up to me once
now I had a driver of the guy come up to
me once and offer me his girlfriend the
driver came up and said hey I'm driving
this couple right now and the man here
would like to let you have his
girlfriend if you'd like and I was like
oh hey hey man no that's so [ __ ]
weird i said 'no that's so weird man I
was like I can't do that because that's
so weird and also no I just didn't want
to be in like any situation like that
man but also why the driver why was the
drive he was like ah this guy hired me
to drive him and yeah but I've gotten
weird [ __ ] I've gone sub you know so
many paintings people come up to me
after shows give me charcoal drawings of
my face which is like sweet they do it
but why the [ __ ] would I want a charcoal
drawing of my face I'm gonna hang up if
I hung up all those in my house my house
would be [ __ ] littered with charcoal
drawings of my face and watercolors of
me on stage
I feel like Donald Trump would hang all
those up of him though I think the White
House is going to be full of them
yeah so yeah I don't know I get weird
[ __ ] though I have people that give me
things also that are like here you go
and and I don't know what they are and
then I'm like well maybe I mentioned
this once on it like on stage and a show
in like Albuquerque or something I don't
know but yeah so so those are the two
questions that I answered today but send
me some more use hashtag congratulations
pod or tweet me but you got to use it
congratulations about those are the ones
I check and then sign up or I sign up I
sound like a [ __ ] old man subscribe to
the please subscribe to the podcast and
then rate and review it that helps a lot
too and it also makes me want to do the
podcast more because this is only number
four and I'm happy still but who knows
what the [ __ ] will happen in the next
few weeks so do that and [ __ ] tell
people about this [ __ ] like your friends
make them [ __ ] sign up please or
otherwise you know I'm gonna lose some
steam uh and then you know I don't know
send me nice messages I guess I don't
really care about that last one but uh
yeah this is congratulations a podcast
and oh go to my website crystally accom
see all the dates coming up I got a
bunch of dates I'm being added and then
my next episode coming up I'll be
talking about I'll be talking about my
spirit of experience in Seattle and
Vancouver shooting my special that's
coming out in this summer this summer
and then that's about it thanks so much
for listening and remember what did we
learn don't play guitar at a party if
you're a geeky teenager definitely don't
do it and you know have some coffee
wonder about life's mysteries and also
what was the other thing I talked about
the main thing don't [ __ ] download a
don't don't call it a radio station and
request a song don't do that actually
because I would love to see the radio
stations turn on their ass and just be
like all wait and we never get requests
anymore
no I'll never work I'm not that big but
to suggest that and have that work but
anyway thanks this is congratulations
the podcast with Chris D'Elia I'm your
host and that's that thanks guys
[Music]
you